[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and after the force
was strong at d23 this weekend Disney
have released online the special look
that was shown at the Expo throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the first look as well as everything you
missed and how this lines up with the
plot details that we already have there
will of course be heavy spoilers here so
if you don't want anything about the
film potentially ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my breakdown of the d23 special
look ok so the trailer opens with the
trip down memory lane that sort of
encapsulates just how much the
Skywalker's have been central to the
entire Star Wars saga and how the newly
introduced characters from episode 7
have pretty much been passed the torch
or rather lightsaber and are now
integral to the progression of the
galaxy we then get a new look at the
upcoming film which shows the resistance
members arriving at a desert planet the
film itself is rumored to center around
a device known as the wayfinder this is
capable of locating an arsenal of
weapons that was hidden by Palpatine
before his death and both the
first-order and resistance are desperate
to get their hands on it in the
beginning of the film this is reported
to kylo by the Knights of Ren who as we
know return for this film the film
reportedly takes place one year after
the last Jedi and due to the events of
that movie the first-order have
conquered the galaxy Hux has been
replaced by a legion general pride
played by Richard II grant and has been
leaking information to the resistance in
the hopes that they kill kylo and allow
him to retake control this is how the
resistance learn of the wayfinder and it
sort becomes the MacGuffin of the entire
movie we see from the first look that
Carrie Fisher is back and according to
the leaks of ROS is now a high-ranking
officer that works with Leia was the
group go off on their expedition to find
a Wayfinder apparently the way finest
coordinates are in c-3po Zoe's memory
unit in an abandoned Imperial blockade
here the heroes befriend the warrior
Jana played by Naomi
and we see in the trailer that c-3po has
red eyes which has many asking questions
in the reported popeck that i covered
recently which he should definitely go
watch after this
c-3po turns evil in the film at one
point due to a combat droid cpu getting
uploaded to his head instead of the
wayfinder and this seems to line up
quite a lot with the first look we next
see the resistance going head to head
with the legion of stardestroyers and
for me this is one of the standout shots
of the trailer you really get the
feeling that this as the end of
everything and it makes for an awesome
image set to the background of the dark
blue sky rey - looks like she's brushing
up on her Jedi's skills and still
training at the Luke Skywalker is no
more though he is rumored to appear as a
force ghost throughout the film we next
see kylo on an ice planet which is where
a part of the wayfinder was said to be
in the leaks from here we cut to the
death star being pulled out the shadows
is right and run fight on it this is
obviously the last action set piece and
it looks like an incredible place to
have a battle that is reminiscent of the
final fight in Revenge of the Sith
apparently the wayfinder leads them to
the Death Star and it's revealed that
the weapons are actually Palpatine
spirit and uses this to possess a member
of the Knights of Ren played by Matt
Smith who will be voicing the character
the possession also seems to line up
with the fact that we see Rey in the
trailer with dog robes and double red
lightsaber which could indicate that the
villain too takes over here though there
is another possibility personally I
don't think that they would give away
their big twist in a trailer like this
and can imagine that it's from the
training scene in which Rey has a vision
similar to Luke in the Empire Strikes
Back
in which she sees herself going to the
dark side and what she would become if
she did I doubt we will get much of this
in the final movie and whilst it's a
cool scene we haven't been building up
three movies for her just join the dark
side at the last minute it's probably
the standout moment of the trailer
though so definitely let me know if you
agree with me or not
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the special look and if there's
anything that I missed them make sure
you leave it in the comment section
below if you want to see the full plot
League breakdown that definitely seems
more legitimate you to this trailer then
make sure you click it at the end I got
over the entire movies plot so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come talk
to me about movies TV shows games and
comic books then you can follow me on
twitter at definition YT it's the best
way to get in touch with me and
the perfect place to suggest new videos
and content well so just one let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of John with three and blu-ray and all
you have to do to be in with the chance
of winning is to like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the star wars
special look in the comment section
below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the bureau will
be shipped out from them to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]